mi piace il brio di degli horror durante
il periodo estivo
in realtà non è periodo estivo state per
iniziare la scuola quindi questo è già
un horror comunque ragazzi siamo tornati
su amnesia dopo 800 vent'anni ci sono
delle mappe in amnesia che fanno i
giocatori delle custom maps ed era da
una vita che non ne usciva un accusi
[ __ ] talmente [ __ ] che è arrivata alle
mie orecchie non lo sentivo parlare di
amnesia da tipo cinque anni se così [ __ ]
io direi di ciò che stiamo tornando
proprio i vecchi tempi e io quando
faceva monesi aero così ama in quechua
al pianoforte quanti pianoforte o
l'orsacchiotto l'ho buttato sul
lampadario quindi i capelli soliste cioè
non solo peggio però lì spero che loro
sia meglio star di new game schema
amadeus che non è quello della cipolla
grazie grazie ci vuole capacità per
schiacciare su start new game e si parte
così va bene sono nel letto buongiorno
ai bebè o solo per il lancio sveglia va
bene bonjour mio personaggino bello vedo
che vive in una casa moderna come tutte
le case di amnesia d'altronde posso
prendere questa roba
no ragazzi non mi ricordo assolutamente
come si gioca da un mese è vecchissimo
sto gioco per i 20 ragazzi questo è
stato uno dei primi giochi che ho fatto
su youtube sono un forse quasi il primo
dopo blender me permesso
e l'atmosfera riesce ancora a prendermi
bene ora che brutta faccia che c'è
questo vaso dimmi un potere
beh io non capisco chi ancora me credo
che si chiami semi ragazze non ne sono
sicuro però credo che si chiami se anche
bello col cane temi seminò d'aveni la
palla fuori la finestra veloce e la
madonna che è di piombo st palla se ti e
botta che dà a facili gas dalla palla
devo ma che c'è un nano c'è un il
professor layton e poi c'è un nano di
fianco va bene non stanno andando via ma
che figata mappe fatto benissimo
io ci sono delle comunque non vedo
perché ti vorresti cagare sotto di due
persone il caso succedendo semi semi se
mi incazzo vedete amici anche bello
shaun le zucche di halloween è visto che
c'era l'altro il caso professor layton
mi scusi ma ci passa gente qua
taci dei camion giorno io vi giuro che
ragazzi e spazio a noi dai professor
layton però sembrava salve uomo baffuto
fortunato lei io non ce la farò mai
baffi ci sarebbe bello grazie avermi
portato in una prigione in una caverna
che quella di the forest il confronto
sono un hotel a cinque stelle ci sono le
a grazie che ciò l'intrattenimento
almeno ha mai aperto grazie pietra
pietro grazie
ma l'avvocato il 66 stata più
intelligente di me non avevo capito che
fosse aperto vabbè permesso mi hanno
portato quali è bellissimo tanto suo
posto per modo di dire ha centrato di
posti brutti questo è uno dei più belli
sorprendere la lanterna no proseguiamo
c'è chi va bene ma mi porto la mia amica
pietra che vedo che ci sta abbastanza
dentro e vieni quasi a chi fa pietra vai
vai vai let's go come ai vecchi tempi
all'arrembaggio in mezzo alle stanze di
amnesia se qualcuno mi corre addosso mi
ammazzo di infarti ma vabè messo fatto
c'era una eccolo aspettami brutta vai a
prenderlo per kakà si cagano addosso
tutti quando vedono
mia amica pietra ce la fai a stare fermo
non c'è solo più in testa porca vacca
non sono proprio campione mondiale di
lancio della pietra però permesso
devo portare la mia amica però che sono
un casino
vai le zio e zia allora primate non
partire senza di me però perfetto by god
i ragazzi siamo carichi tutti pronti
ragazzi l'importante è andare a fondo
della faccenda allora vi dove la mia
amica pietra mi fa piacere che in fondo
asta caverna ci siano tutte queste
cagate per carità sono contento però
ma chi è ma che l'uomo dietro il drappo
tarzan e il signore del drappo no e
tarzan il signore del drappo se non
fosse che non ho idea di dove siamo
mancati i quadri ma hanno rifatto anche
i quadri è questa notte di altri governo
ora sì che sono difeso come si deve
permesso io comunque con la mia amica
pietra andrei molto molto più tranquillo
però va bene se mi spunta qualcosa da un
momento all'altro vi ammazzo l'esco a
gesù che bene alla vista ho guardato con
questo vessillo addosso non poter avere
un'espressione diversa da questa credimi
sono un tizio che entrate era nelle
caverne poi sono uscito non è permesso
prendetevi male
ok
cosa scusa ho sentito e non tarda ti
faccio diventare una tromba non ti
azzardare mai più che quello che sono
alle mie spalle ma ti pare da solo tra
l'altro va beh ma c'è un'altra senza una
vista c'è una tassa o che bello non
nonno che trova un'altra diapositiva che
bello il disegno e precarietà
chi è che sta bussando dovrei che bussa
avanti la porta è stata sbarrata qua
come come faccio uscire scusami stavolta
ma basta che chi sta bussando di qua a
dirlo subito cioè campanello comunque a
zio salve la madonna che ansia di vivere
vero kazmi spuntano quelli delle
diapositive di prima giro chiesto tacco
di lascio youtube propria ma stiamo
arrivando da qualche parte di chi option
labirinto
credo sia un labirinto no è una tomba
ancora meglio guarda madonna i corvi ci
mancavano solo quelli guarda alla era un
labirinto ci aveva azzeccato allora
carino mi piacciono i giochi così cioè
dove mi fanno cagare sti giochi e giusto
sono tornato davvero prima ho trovata ma
sai che ce l'ho fatta sono bravissimo
nei labirinti una bella [ __ ] beh
giustamente non mi aspettavo altrove a
me non è finito era un checkpoint quindi
ok però se mi spuntano i bambini nani
con un problema
cap a ca marta calmazzo te lo giuro
vado dove andato il bambino giusto per
ci sono i rumori stranissimi sottofondo
non sto capendo il senso madonna via via
via via questo può ma eccola qua mi sei
mancata un sacco vieni qua o al concerto
di marty gaal riferisce ho azzeccato
every bari puglia casa tutte che mira se
ci riprovano mille volte non ci riescono
e comunque la pietra io la prendo che
come meccanismo di difesa e super
efficace da lancio dai bambini quelli
che scompaia hanno assunto nato a sono
dall'altra parte ok ok ok non ho capito
no devi stare deve essere la mia parte
non chiudermi le porte in faccia ti
prego che già difficile salve
no no no no no perché perché perché ci
hai la madre che fa questo lavoro tutto
perché non vedo niente se mi si
esaurisce la lanterna maledizione questo
posto
vade retro asilo proprio quella madonna
che brutta roba vedo non mi saltate in
bocca per cortesia mi riguarda pittorico
mi sono un sacco riconoscente anche se
non lo sapete ancora però simpatici
io li amo i bambini giuro led di avere
sempre più allegre e sostanze
l'importante è arrivare a destinazione
non so dove la strada dove sia la
destinazione però fa piacere che ci
siano sti quadri bellissimi veramente
delle [ __ ] sa mica qualcosa nei
cassetti a parte le bottiglie una chiave
non l'avrei mai detto chiave nel secondo
piano la stanza principale allora devo
tornare lì porca vacca trovata la chiave
il secondo piano ci speravo mai di poter
accedere al secondo piano di gioco però
sempre allegra e la musica mi raccomando
e questa teoria ora vediamo dove ci
portano queste belle porte che allegria
vale la stessa regola di prima se ti
muovi ti sculaccia anche perché se
veramente brutto per non volevo dirtelo
e questo succede se tenete l'acqua al
lavandino troppo aperta ai ragazzi
amnesia e che bello aver riportato
amnesia giuro sono contentissimo però
che vi sia piaciuto
grazie mille alle tenebre che sono
sempre stati miei compagni di vita negli
horror nel mio che sul mio canale grazie
a dio sono youtube che vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi come se non mi piace anche a
verità giocando una partita così siete
ci viviamo hanno proseguito da ragazzi
[Musica]